my name is brittany broski but most  people know me as kombucha girl life was  very normal for me i had no idea what  was coming i downloaded tik tok as a  joke  i didn't even know what kombucha was and  uh i just kind of wanted to try got home  put all my groceries away set up my  camera and just filmed me trying it  no  well  it didn't do well on tick tock it was  downloaded and uploaded to gay twitter i  dm the guy who first uploaded the video  and i was like hey like this is me  in hopes that he would take it down  because i was like i don't want to get  fired but he was like oh this is you and  tagged me under it and i was like oh  [ __ ] where i was pulled into my boss's  office or enough i mean a week later  like she brought me in slid a piece of  paper across the table and was like you  know  i think we're gonna let you go  i was mortified i was so embarrassed to  tell my dad